[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sociétés sur tv 78 chaque
mois l'actualité vue sous l'angle du
documentaire aujourd'hui il est question
du handicap tout au long de l'année 2018
l'école des parents de guyancourt va à
s'intéresser à ce sujet sensible pour
tenter de répondre aux questionnements
des parents nous parlerons de tout cela
avec nos invités ce soir daniel vial
adjoint au maire de guyancourt chargé
notamment des solidarités avec également
isabelle duclos responsable de l'école
des parents de guyancourt et elodie
raciale lefebvre et psychologues ont
soit à vous trois
pour débuter je vous propose néanmoins
de découvrir le documentaire de pippo
delbono intitulé la visite le château de
versailles
il y est question des déambulations dans
ce cadre royal de bobo microcéphale
sourd et muet il a passé plus de
quarante ans en hôpital psychiatrique et
on se retrouve en plateau juste après
de retour sur le plateau de tv soixante
dix huit pour ce numéro du 7 8 sociétés
avec ce mois ci la thématique du
handicap et de la famille vous venez de
découvrir donc un documentaire issues de
la collection de courts métrages
proposés par dix auteurs réalisateurs
avec à 10 rencontres de personnes en
situation de handicap mental dans dix
grands lieux de culture je vous
représente mes invités si vous venez de
nous rejoindre daniel vialla qui est
adjointe au maire de guyancourt chargé
notamment des solidarités isabelle
duclos qui est responsable de l'école
des parents de guyancourt et elodie
raciale lefebvre qui est psychologue une
nouvelle fois bienvenue à vous trois sur
ce plateau
le message véhiculé dans le court
métrage le documentaire que nous venons
de devoir finalement c'est que la beauté
de la vie c'est la différence c'est ce
canton dé dire le réalisateur nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans une époque
d'obligations de conformité alors que
finalement la vraie richesse reste la
diversité pour introduire peut-être un
peu la thématique est ce que en tant que
psychologue vous êtes aussi d'accord et
c'est dans les grandes lignes on va
détailler tout à l'heure mais le message
que vous véhiculez auprès des parents il
faut aussi prendre en compte la
différence c'est pas le livre comme
difficulté forcément alors oui en même
temps c'est très compliqué à soutenir
comme discours puisque déjà il ya une
première chose qui me paraît importante
à souligner ces cas notion de handicap a
beaucoup évolué ces quarante dernières
années et que maintenant le handicap
prend en compte un certain nombre de
problématiques très diverses
donc sous le couvert du handicap on
parle de handicaps physiques n'ont pas
aussi un handicap mental et depuis
quelques temps maintenant de handicap
psychique
donc c'est des problématiques
extrêmement variés et du même coup qui
complexifie aussi beaucoup les prises en
charge et est qui et qui détermine que
les professionnels soient un peu plus
ajustés s'ajuste au plus près de 2 de
ces problématiques
donc c'est à la fois bien sûr une
comment dire une dimension globale mais
sans oublier qu'à une singularité aux
fonctions d audi qu à ça ça me paraît
très important
vous avez travaillé sur ces
problématiques le plus compliqué lorsque
le handicap survient dans une famille
c'est aussi de prendre en compte le fait
qu'il y aura un remaniement complet de
cette cellule famille
oui il ya forcément un remaniement
complet déjà il ya le temps de la non ce
qui me paraît très particulier mais
avant ça il ya aussi le temps de de
l'incertitude avant le diagnostic un
temps qui peut être extrêmement long je
pense à des familles qui attendent
parfois des années avant d'avoir un
diagnostic précis donc tout ce temps là
à prendre en compte est souvent le
diagnostic déterminé prise en charge
d'élire cas il ya tout un temps parfois
de plusieurs années où les familles sont
confrontés à l'incertitude et à la tente
d'un diagnostic puis deux puis de prise
en charge
donc ça c'est aussi c'est aussi voilà
une valeur déterminante parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'en général les familles qui
sont touchées par le handicap vivent
effectivement un coup de tonnerre
absolument dévastateur et à tous pendus
parce que ça ça ça vient remettre en
cause toute la question générationnelle
ça vient toucher bien sûr la question
des fratries
et puis ça vieux visé aussi une manière
très prégnante à question du couple
conjugal et ski ski avant si on
familiale également puisé leurs gagnants
un des parents est obligé d'arrêter de
travailler parce qu'il n'ya pas les
structures adéquates forcément pour
accueillir l'enfant handicapé est un des
parents est obligé d'arrêter de
travailler ce qui entraîne aussi des
conditions financières différentes et
des problèmes qui justement vont générer
quelques fois des problèmes de couple
des problèmes familiaux ou vraiment
intense
il faut dire aussi que très souvent
cette problématique parentalité handicap
touche beaucoup les familles et
notamment on retrouve beaucoup de
familles monoparentales c'est vrai que
c'est c'est une vraie problématique
quand le handicap vient percuter la
famille ça effectivement chamboule la
famille le couple et du coup on voit là
on est amené à trouver beaucoup de
familles monoparentales qui cumulent les
difficultés quand les handicaps bouscule
la famille c'est la thématique de ce
sept huit sociétés ce mois-ci vous
l'avez compris avec nos différents
invités qui sont en plateau puisque au
début de cette année 2010 8 l'école des
parents de guyancourt propose de s'y
attarder et d'apporter des réponses
concrètes aussi dans ces familles qui
sont en attente qui ont beaucoup de
questionnements je vais on va dérouler
un petit peu le programme on peut déjà
dire que le 30 janvier
30 vous interviendrez en tant que
psychologue à la maison de quartier de
théodore monod
on va revenir aussi sur les autres
interventions pendant six mois daniel
vialla isabelle duclos donc jusqu'en
juin la thématique du handicap et de la
famille est abordée pourquoi avoir fait
ce choix déjà tout d'abord il y avait
une forte demande aussi peut-être
alors oui il y avait une forte demande
maintenant c'est vrai que l'école des
parents de guyancourt s'adresse à tous
les parents et c'est vrai que parents et
professionnels puisque on oublie souvent
mais il ya aussi cette dimension
donc pour nous c'était important
effectivement de traiter cette
thématique parce qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation dans le parcours éducatif du
parent cette famille elle peut être
traversé par des choses qui la renforce
par des choses qui est là qui la
fragilise par des expériences de
multiples et variées et puis bang
billancourt n'échappe pas à cette règle
et ces familles elles se trouvent
parfois bien isolée où on a on a abordé
effectivement là la notion de couple et
de difficultés dans la famille élargie
mais l' isolement voilà l'isolément
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
difficile et comme c'est pas forcément
un thème parce qu'il est sensible qui
est très souvent abordés et bien voilà
je pense que c'était important que dans
nos missions d'accompagnement des
parents tout au long de l'éducation on
puisse aborder ça aussi on peut aussi
préciser que c'est une structure
municipale voilà ce qui explique aussi
les la raison de votre présence ici je
voulais m'y attarder parce que on en
parlait juste avant de débuter
l'enregistrement de cette émission c'est
une des premières écoles des parents en
tout cas dans les yvelines
il ya eu marre et il ya eu paris et puis
à ugly en cours c'était 2001 c'était
bien c'était 2001 donc ça date déjà de
quelques années donc c'est vrai que sur
guyancourt il ya toujours eu
cette politique de la lutte contre les
inégalités de la lutte de la lutte aussi
contre les discriminations le handicap
c'est la compétence du département mais
au niveau de guyancourt on appris de 7,7
ce thème à coeur et on a mis une
politique en place sur on va dire trois
fronts l'accessibilité qui est quand
même une obligation aussi pour les
collectivités l'éducation donc j'aurai
peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler et
puis l'insertion
donc c'est vrai que on a on a mis en
place une commission communale
d'accessibilité de façon à rendre
accessibles tous les erp et toutes les
établissements publics tous les
établissements publics wi qui reçoivent
du public
et puis au niveau de la delà de
l'éducation on est quand même une
commune où il ya des classes en
insertion scolaire
on a cinq ulysse donc ce sont ces
fameuses unités scolaires d'insertion
pour les handicapés je suis cité
simplement mais dans le premier degré on
a une ulis malvoyants 2 ulysses
malentendants et 2 ulysses troubles du
comportement et au niveau du collège
paraît y en a deux collèges qui ont des
places avec des épaules d'insertion
comme ça pour pour le handicap et même
au lycée hôtelier il ya également ce
genre de structure donc
une chose qui est importante aussi il
n'ya pas que le scolaire mais il ya
aussi le centre de loisirs du fun pour
tous ce que vous en avez déjà l'occasion
de la rencontre l'occasion le casque des
rencontres et c'est donc c'est aussi
quelque chose qui n'existait pas c'est
envisager un centre de loisirs qui
reçoit des enfants handicapés
parce que c'est vrai que comme je disais
tout à l'heure les parents qui se
retrouvent en difficulté parce qu'ils
ont un enfant handicapé
s'il ya des structures scolaires qui
acceptent l'enfant handicapé à la fin de
la journée scolaire
que se passe-t-il le parent est obligé
de récupérer son enfant les mercredis
aussi est donc cette structure-là du fun
pour tous
j'en parle vraiment avec beaucoup de
sentiments parce que c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne très bien qui a eu
beaucoup de mal à se mettre en place
parce que c'était c'était inconnu
s'était c'était peut-être pas aussi des
sujets que tout le monde aimait évoqué
parce que c'est vrai c'est sensible
comme disait isabelle et donc voilà donc
c'est sur la commune de cette action
pour faire en sorte que les différences
soient le plus élevés possible surtout
par rapport à l'enfant donc il ya ce
genre d'exemple je pourrais en donner
d'autres sur cette thématique du
handicap comment on s'organise aussi un
petit peu les choses y aura différentes
rencontres des débats pendant pendant
six mois d'ailleurs je vais rebondir
puisque du fun pour tous sera partenaire
bien sûr de ce cycle effectivement ils
ont commencé par par cet espace de
loisirs pour les enfants en situation de
handicap
mais depuis peu ils ont aussi monté un
lieu d'accueil enfants parents qui
semble essentiel dans la parentalité
puisque c'est vraiment un lieu où des
parents d'enfants de 0 à 6 ans non
scolarisés peuvent venir avec leur
enfant est donc partagé un moment de
rencontre d' échanges entre parents mais
aussi accompagnés de professionnels et
cette particularité qui donc ce lieu
d'accueil enfants parents qui s'appelle
un deux trois soleil qui se trouve dans
les locaux de l'association a cette
particularité c'est que il accueille des
parents avec enfants en situation de
handicap et à un jour d'aujourd'hui il y
en a très très peu voire pas et
et parce qu'on sait à quel point c'est
difficile de se mélanger avec des
parents qui ont des enfants qui nous
keane qui n'ont pas de difficulté
particulière
et donc voilà donc ils seront
partenaires donc je tenais à le préciser
alors ils avaient reviennent pas
particulièrement par contre on a une
volonté de faire de l'information autour
de ce lieu puisque les parents qui
viendront aussi que seront concernés et
donc voilà comme c'est pas trés c'est
assez récent on va dire ce lieu il était
important pour nous de le préciser en
tant que centre de loisirs dont excès il
ya quelques années c'est sérieux vieux
de 29 ans
c'est récent et oui c'est ça il a il a
deux trois ans donc il est vraiment
récent dans le paysage
et puis surtout il est vraiment unique
voilà donc sinon il plusieurs thèmes
seront abordés et ce sera à la fois des
rencontres plutôt intime sous forme de
groupes de parents parce que aussi c'est
important le collectif les parents ont
besoin d'entendre de s'informer mais ils
ont aussi besoin de partager des
expériences entre eux et le petit groupe
s'y prêtent davantage donc autour de ce
petit groupe sera traitée l'adolescence
l'adolescent date de naissance et le
handicap donc voilà j'ai la volonté
d'émancipation et bien sûr de ses
instructions et qu'est ce que ça fait en
tant qu'adolescent de traverser cette
période mais qu'est ce que ça fait en
tant que parent aussi s'est jamais
simple à l'adolescence mais quand le
handicap bien voilà ça vient un peu
exacerbé toutes ces étapes en fait de
l'éducation
mais bien sûr on abordera aussi et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure la fratrie
parce que la fratrie ça aussi c'est
comme l'adolescence c'est des périodes
voilà qui sont jamais simples les
parents se posent beaucoup de questions
mais quand le handicap arrive
voilà comment qu'on aborde comme en
abordant la fratrie et tous qui traverse
cette famille et puis un thème aussi qui
me tient à coeur parce que voilà l'école
des parents a toujours été un peu
novatrice dans les thématiques et là
encore une fois on on est un peu
novateur puisque c'est un thème qu'on
entend rarement ces voix là je suis
parent en situation de handicap et je
souhaite un enfant et et voilà ils
comment je fais comment je traverse a
comme enjeu m'affronte aussi aux
difficultés aux freins dans ma propre
famille dans le monde médical non dans
tout ce qui m'entoure et c'est une
intervenante madame idiart qui est sage
femme
qui elle même en situation de handicap
qui travaille à l'institut montsouris et
qui nous fera le plaisir et l'honneur de
venir échanger avec nous et ça je
voulais vraiment parler puisque c'est
vraiment un thème qu'on entend d'abord
très rarement l'école des parents à
guyancourt qui proposent tous ses rendez
vous et bien sûr c'est le programme
complet est un art est à retrouver sur
le site internet de la ville voilà pour
bien voir toutes les dates on parlait
tout à l'heure notamment du travail sur
le désir d'émancipation de ces
adolescents en situation de handicap
c'est une problématique particulière
comment on peut accompagner à la fois
les parents pour leur dire mon
adolescence est compliquée et en plus
comme un handicap ce sera encore plus
compliqué puis aussi accompagner ces
jeunes mais déjà du côté des parents je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose de
particulièrement compliqué à
l'adolescence pour les parents je pense
notamment au maire c'est que se font les
maires se sont dévoués corps et âme si
on peut dire à à la prise en charge de
leurs enfants dans le soin dans le soin
du corps notamment dans un certain
nombre de choses et il s'agit pour à ce
moment là au moment de l'adolescence
pour ses parents pour les mères pour les
pères aussi en bien sûr et de lâcher
quelque chose de cette de cette prise en
charge et de ceux liés en particulier
par exemple très concrètement pour des
mères il s'agira un moment donné de
pouvoir reprendre une vie active un
professionnel par exemple de vie sociale
tout ça s'est mis en en
j'allais dire en suspens ou en jachère
pendant parfois que de nombreuses années
donc du côté des parents il ya tout un
travail je crois d'accompagnement pour
leur permettre de réinvestir d'autres
espaces et puis et puis du côté du de
l'adolescent là il ya aussi tout un
travail j'allais dire du côté de
l'autonomie psychique de s'autoriser
comme tous les adolescents du monde à
pouvoir imaginer des choix
professionnels des choix de tes choix
d'objets d'amour etc et et là où c'est
un peu plus compliqué bien sûr séquences
et quand par exemple pour des
adolescents empêché physiquement en
fauteuil et cetera c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué l'addition dû sortir sortir
pour aller voir les copains etc
c'est compliqué parce que se rajoute
aussi une dernière chose ils n'auraient
plein de choses à dire
une chose qui me viendrait c'est la
question de l'inquiétude des parents
aussi a lâché du regard des enfants
devenus grands et qu'ils sentent
toujours très venir à bout que c'est
vraiment des questions je crois qu'elle
a un double accompagnement aussi bien du
côté des parents que du côté des
adolescents alors il y aura différentes
réponses qui seront proposés d
accompagnement psychologique 1 pour
aider mais est ce que le but c'est
l'objectif aussi de ce qui est proposé
un réduit en course ce sera aussi
d'aider les parents à trouver des pistes
la chaussée plus rationnel on va dire
mais matérielle financière est ce que
vous les aider aussi à trouver les
bonnes structures à s'adresser aux bons
interlocuteurs parce que là aussi on
peut être démuni en tant que parents
lorsqu'il faut faire face au handicap
parce que c'est un coût financier alors
dans au sein de nos différentes
rencontres pas forcément mis à la
boutique des parents qu'elle a de toute
façon et qui est là à l'année on se
trouve au centre ville à côté de l'hôtel
de ville à guyancourt et là
effectivement on est aussi point info
famille et cette thématique on laborde
toute l'année et on l'abordera d'autant
plus à ce moment-là parce que on est
aussi là effectivement pour les
accompagner dans ses démarches
mais par ailleurs on aura aussi dans ce
cadre là une soirée d'information sur
les procédures et notamment tout ce qui
est ou scolarisation handicap tout ce
qui est de l'inclusion et c'est ça aussi
c'est un sujet difficile et sensible et
qui touche à la fois les parents bien
sûr à travers leurs enfants mais qui
touche aussi bobo
bon nombre de professionnels parce qu'il
se trouve aussi dans des situation
délicate d'accueillir des enfants en
situation de handicap dans la
scolarisation et ça ce sera une soirée
où là on sera plus sur les choses
concrètes sur la procédure sur comment
on fait comment vers qui on se tourne et
comment quelles sont les démarches
administratives
mais au-delà de ce cycle où il ya ce
qu'on peut rajouter également c'est que
on a créé un poste
guyancourt dans le cadre du secteur
social qui est une personne dédiée à
l'aide aux personnes âgées et aux
personnes handicapées de poser comment
la ville justement intervenait en outre
que ce poste on m'a créé il ya
maintenant deux ans et demi et il répond
vraiment un besoin que ce soit pour des
adultes ou pour des parents avec des
enfants qu'on peut adresser après à
l'école des parents
donc c'est un cetain une personne qui
qui est compétente dans tout ce qui est
administratif liées au handicap qui peut
orienter qui peut conseiller qui peut
instruire les dossiers
donc on a consacré un poste à cette
activité
et on a aussi une politique tarifaire
spécifique à guyancourt puisque une
famille qui a handicapé dans sa dent
dans seront en son sein eh bien il ya un
abattement pour la taxe d'habitation par
exemple le prend en considération cette
chose là et cet abattement peu peut
aussi s'additionner à un abattement qui
existent aussi pour les familles
nombreuses ou pour les familles qui
n'ont pas suffisamment pour financer
normal est correct quand les handicaps
bouscule la famille c'est la thématique
dans les grandes lignes qui sera abordé
par l'école des parents nous ayant cours
à partir de ce mois ci à partir de ce
mois de janvier jusqu'à l'été ont
reparlé des enfants parler des fratries
de la famille de réaction du couple des
parents est ce que vous allez aborder
aussi la problématique des parents cette
fois ci qui on l'a handicapé par la
suite et est du coup comment réagissent
les enfants cette fois ci on est dans
une autre problématique est ce que ce
sera l'objet aussi d'intervention alors
oui tout à fait mais alors là plutôt
dans le cadre de la médiation familiale
puisque là en se mettra du côté des
fratries qui doivent pas ce que c'est ça
aussi une famille on parle de la
naissance on parle de la grossesse on
parle de l'adolescence on parle des
fratries par l'odeur d'autonomie aussi
de la perte d'autonomie et ça c'est
quelque chose aussi qui est d'actualité
puisque voilà dans les années qui vont
venir on va être confronté de plus en
plus à ces problématiques et ses parents
qui qui qui perd de l'autonomie les
familles doivent trouver des solutions
et ils sont souvent ou s'ils en parlent
d'isolement et ce souvent compliqué et
surtout ça vient généré au sein de cette
famille ça vient généré au sein de cette
fratrie des choses des conflits parce
que beaucoup de choses de l'enfant se
remonte et prises de décisions très
difficiles et tout ça ça vient vraiment
rejouer des choses qui se sont ancrés
depuis des années et c'est vraiment pas
vraiment une période difficile pour ces
familles et nous on a souhaité pouvoir
les accompagner au tour d'une médiation
familiale et donc c'est l'association
apm médiation de versailles qui
intervient déjà par ailleurs à
guyancourt et à la boutique des parents
plutôt sur la thématique de la
séparation qui l'a vraiment mettra
l'accent sur l'accompagnement ces
familles autour de la perte d'autonomie
de haut de nos ascendants
c'est en danger aussi pour les pour les
communes
la base autonomie et l accompagnement
bien sûr ça c'est un travail qui est
fait
au sein du secteur social notamment la
création du poste que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure pour les personnes handicapées
citons qu on appelle le poste pap h donc
personnel âgées personnes handicapées
c'est aussi suivre la perte d'autonomie
et favoriser le maintien à domicile si
la personne on est d'accord bien entendu
et puis faire en sorte que les aidants
parce que ça c'est un problème aussi les
aidants sont quelquefois plus fatigués
ou vont quelquefois vers la mort plus
vite que la personne vieillissante où la
personne handicapée vieillissant c'est
un un sujet national on en parle
régulièrement là on a beaucoup parlé des
aidants familiaux
il ya quelques temps mais il faut
trouver des solutions aussi pour leur
permettre de d'avoir des temps de repos
de façon à pouvoir continuer à être
personnage est dans la famille le fil
directeur le fil conducteur de toutes
les thématiques on a abordé c'est
surtout le fait de lutter contre
l'isolément des familles c'est un petit
peu oui je crois qu'on pourrait résumer
ça comme ça toutes les difficultés c'est
ou ne pas parler de la question du
regard qui meurent est la question
peut-être va dire fondatrice de toutes
les difficultés c'est à dire que le la
personne handicapée mais aussi
l'entourage est confronté au regard et
ce regard il est toujours j'allais dire
toujours en trop ou toujours en pas
assez c'est à dire toujours en trop
c'est à dire qu'il peut être aussi très
très intrusif perçue comme telle en tout
cas ce qui fait que beaucoup de familles
vont vont s'isoler de des espaces
publics par exemple je pense à des
parents qui vont plus aller aux et
emmener leurs enfants dans des parcs ou
dans les eaux dans des endroits
beaucoup trop intrusif ont trop violent
et puis un regard en pas assez parce
qu'effectivement ils sont aussi
confrontée à l'indifférence voix
voilà sa position de retrait que chacun
d'entre nous peut avoir un moment donné
ça ça ça renvoie des représentations
extrêmement compliqué le handicap pour
tout le monde donc je crois que c'est
vraiment effectivement la question
d'isolement qui est au coeur de doudou
l'idée de créer un maximum de relais
possible à toutes les étapes de la vie
de ces personnes si vous souhaitez
ajouter quelque chose alors je voulais
dire quand même que en dehors de ce
cycle l'école des parents de toutes
façons continuera à traiter cette
thématique qu'effectivement au travail
en transversalité et que tout ce qui se
fait globalement sur guyancourt va être
mis en avant par l'école des parents et
ceux de toute façon dont le travail
quotidien puisque voilà nos missions
c'est d'accompagner les parents d'avant
la naissance jusqu'à la majorité de
l'enfant dans toutes les étapes de
l'éducation très bien merci à toutes les
trois d'avoir participé à ce 7,8
la société la programmation de l'école
des parents autour du handicap et est
détaillé sur le site de la ville de
guyancourt je vous le disais tout à
l'heure
les programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne à très bientôt pour un nouveau 7
8 sociétés
[Musique]